hora de la información económica aquí en
directo América de France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
Daniela Blandón Daniela bienvenida vamos
a empezar hablando con uno de los temas
más importantes del día y es Sudán estos
conflictos que están ocurriendo y que de
alguna manera también han golpeado la
economía Claro que sí y se originaron en
la economía Valentina porque Omar alreir
fue derrocado en abril de 2019 después
de casi tres décadas en el poder como lo
hemos venido relatando y ese golpe de
estado tiene un origen económico porque
se dio justamente después de las
protestas generalizadas por las casas de
alimentos combustible y efectivo que se
prolongó durante meses esta nación rica
en recursos naturales tiene más de 46
millones de habitantes de los cuales
casi una cuarta parte está en riesgo de
inseguridad alimentaria según Naciones
Unidas que crea además que casi la mitad
son niños el país también cuenta con una
de las reservas de oro más grandes del
continente y qué papel tiene el oro en
este conflicto un papel muy importante
porque los militares controlan la mayor
parte de la economía del país pero el
grupo militar paramilitar denominado
fuerzas de apoyo rápido administra las
principales zonas mineras de oro una
fuente clave de ingresos para esta
poderosa milicia ahora la situación
amenaza con empeorar ya metiéndonos en
el terreno Y es que hay millones de
sudaneses atrapados en sus hogares desde
que estalló repentinamente esta
violencia el fin de semana los
suministros de alimentos ya están
disminuyendo y en un país que ya viene
con problemas porque según los últimos o
los más recientes datos del Banco
Mundial la inflación esta nación al
terminar el 2021 estaba casi en 400 por
ciento pues terrible grave esta
situación Daniela nosotros vamos a
cambiar de tema venimos a América vamos
a hablar de Estados Unidos los
principales bancos de este país están
reportando resultados en un primer
trimestre que tuvo
importantes movimientos bastante
sacudones claro Valentina y es que el
mercado siempre está muy pendiente cada
trimestre de cómo les está yendo las
empresas y qué mejor termómetro que los
bancos al menos cuatro de los
principales iniciaron este año con
crecimientos en utilidades es el caso de
JP Morgan de Bank of America de City
Club y de Wells Fargo cada uno tuvo
alzas entre el 7 y el 52% en sus
utilidades dependiendo del caso sin
embargo en los reportes del sistema
financiero estadounidense desde ya se
están generando alertas por el alza en
el número de deudores que están entrando
en Mora en los pagos de sus obligaciones
Especialmente los correspondientes a las
compras con tarjeta de crédito esos
resultados entonces traen mensajes
confusos para Wall Street por ejemplo el
gigante de los bancos de inversión
hoy presentó un reporte decepcionante
con ganancias que cayeron
19%. su presidente ejecutivo David
salmon aseguró que los nervios por la
turbulencia bancaria ya son del pasado
Sin embargo también reconoció que estos
eventos en el sector están reduciendo
las expectativas de crecimiento y que
existe un mayor riesgo de contracciones
crediticias que era lo que estábamos
hablando porque el entorno está
limitando ese apetito de los bancos de
otorgar créditos y la gente no tiene con
qué pagar Pues los bancos tampoco van a
querer prestar Claro pues vamos a estar
muy pendientes de Cómo se desarrolla
esto en Estados Unidos Daniela vamos
ahora con Los indicadores económicos de
la jornada Wall Street de cerro plano
con el mercado muy pendiente de todos
estos resultados de resultados de las
empresas por ejemplo Johnson y Johnson
cayó casi tres por ciento en bolsa tras
advertir sobre el impacto persistente de
los colts de Los costos impulsados por
la inflación en Europa la bolsa de París
marcó nuevo récord de este martes tras
conocerse buenos datos macroeconómicos
en China entre otras cosas y en este
continente me quedo porque los
reguladores antimonopolio allanaron hoy
a algunas empresas del sector de la moda
en varios países tienen la sospecha de
que pudieron haber violado las reglas de
competencia aunque no dio nombres hace
poco fue con el sector de las fragancias
Ahora es con el de la ropa Bueno vamos a
finalizar con la cifra del día Valentina
los 1300 millones de dólares que obtuvo
en ganancias el gigante Netflix en el
primer trimestre de 2023 con un descenso
anual del 18% sus ingresos subieron un
4% al pasar los 8 mil millones de
dólares pero la noticia que le tengo y
no sé si usted vaya a ser de las
damnificadas Yo sí es que Netflix
comenzó el año con un estallido en
suscriptores pero a todos ellos a sus un
millón 750 mil suscriptores él les hizo
una advertencia Y es que va a obtener
ingresos de los que se están
aprovechando de las contraseñas
compartidas para ver Su contenido en
Enero ya había indicado que impondría
restricciones más estrictas a finales de
marzo eso no sucedió en por ejemplo en
Estados Unidos pero si dice que lo va a
hacer a finales de junio se acaba ron
las contraseñas de la familia que todos
ven con el Pero bueno menos mal no
sucedió porque eso lo hemos hecho todos
en todas las plataformas pero conozco
ningún usuario de Netflix que no
comparta sus contraseña con sus
familiares Pues ahora nos van a
restringir Daniela usted muchas gracias
por esta ampliación económica la invito
a que continúe con nosotros que nosotros
continuamos con directo a